[Music]
when i was little maybe five or six
years old my older brother damian he was
two years older than me he was having
some
issues with bullies in school
and so my parents thought it might be a
good idea for him to take some
self-defense lessons uh go to karate
because i admired him so much i wanted
to follow him into everything
my main recollection from my time
i almost said playing karate doing
karate was um i had a huge crush on this
girl who was i think in my brother's
class she was a redhead she reminded me
of annie little orphan annie yes or
annie oakley oh little orphan you think
as a five-year-old i had a crush on
annie oakley i'm surprised you had a
crush on anybody at five years old oh
yeah my first grade teacher mrs farrell
uh carrie fisher and returning to the
gym you're an active little boy
yeah
i enjoyed the ladies
back then
and um and so i remember her being in a
she was in a higher skill level she was
in a class
i think she was like an orange or yellow
belt she had a colored belt
and i remember being very self-conscious
when i'd because all the kids had to
wait in the lobby
for their parents to pick them up and i
i used to take my white belt off right
away so she wouldn't see that i had
a white belt and that my uniform i had
the smallest size but i was so tiny that
uh it still didn't fit i had to roll up
my sleeves on that on one of those i
forget what they call them get keys geez
oh yeah is that am i right i think so i
pulled that from
um probably your chat with our guest
today maybe so uh stay tuned
stay toned
that's what i was trying to do i was
trying to slip yeah stay toned karate is
great exercise
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your story-filled host justin long life
could be a dream
and with me as always is um
my equally self-defensible brother
wouldn't you say we're equally
self-defensible is that a word i don't
think so is that an adjective
self-defensible
you you're equally good at are you
trying to say that i'm capable of
self-defense as as capable as i am yeah
um how would you say that now we're at
or then
uh
not then you were like two
i i could i could have kicked your ass
then i gotta say your timeline seems a
little off really i don't five or six
doing karate yeah i know it sounds
strange doesn't it uh but i just
remember going to see i'm i'm basically
it's definitely off now
yeah because i remember damian doing
karate really clearly and i wouldn't
have remembered that you know who would
remember
damian let's get him on the phone um no
i i bet i bet i was
about seven or eight and i bet you were
about 10.
and i bet he was 12.
what yeah
no really i think so do you know how i
would have done karate at eight you did
no way wrong he you think yeah i'm
pretty confident do you remember when he
did that frank that doesn't mean that
you weren't a horny five-year-old but i
just don't know if that has anything to
do with this story well i do remember
having a crush for sure on my first
grade teacher i know
and i was so nervous because i had an r
problem i had a very bad argument i
couldn't say do you say our problem now
is that passe i don't think you can say
a problem you were our challenge yes
that's you can't say problem you were
differently
yeah i said ours differently
i didn't say them the way i met
traditional traditionally they're said
traditionally
i said them a widow differently a little
like elmer fudd yes and uh what's wrong
with them oh well there's nothing wrong
with that i mean he was uh a second
amendment person i would imagine elmer
fudd and he was certainly not a vegan we
don't talk about politics no show just
sorry um but anyway uh i do remember
going to see damian's play the
frankenstein one sir frankie's hideaway
oh let do you remember that yeah he was
probably in fifth grade okay okay which
means he was
oh which means you were nine which means
i was six oh you're right okay all right
all right all right all right so anyway
so what a fine i did karate when i was
anyway timeline outstanding you did
karate for a week who cares yeah i'll
tell you who cares
i care because it has to do with our
guest today wow
you know you're in line uh a tie up like
that as segway like that puts you in
line for a shortie is that uh the award
yeah yeah i just found out that they're
podcast awards what what what did we get
nominated for um i don't know i don't
know i'll have to check that out yeah
check it out uh no i don't we didn't get
nominated for anything but um our friend
former guest the show donald faison's
show got nominated that's cool fake
doctor's real friends uh it's really
good
and we love donald trump so speaking of
oh yes sorry you were uh i got derailed
to promote somebody else's podcast you
were
you were a little kid who did karate
yeah for a week for about a week who
knows how old you were but you were a
kid who knows if it was a week maybe it
was a year or who knows if you even did
it you know it's funny the old man
dreamt this annie no sorry no no no that
i know isn't that funny that's the most
concrete that's the only part i can be
certain of is that i remember seeing
that little redheaded girl in uh in
class being very self-conscious of where
she was and if she was looking at me and
loved annie but we've talked too much
about it we've talked about this before
that you started um
you started getting an interest in girls
at such a young age it really you don't
remember it baffles me that you were
that young
with that any i know like it's not
sexual at that age but even like i was
so intrigued you were intrigued by and i
and i just wasn't okay like when we
watch when you'd watch religiously
superman 3
uh you don't remember annette o'toole
being like into an edo tool
who's that lana lang oh yeah yeah well
now i realize that she's an attractive
one but at the time weren't you drawn to
her no i was much more drawn to superman
no i know me too but like that didn't
excite you at all it did an intrigue i'm
telling you the first time i ever
was excited in any way by a girl jenny
mccarthy third grade who was that i'm
not gonna say on the show
third grade third grade wow okay what is
i was like nine eight yeah that's not
that far from when i started
when they started peaking my interest
why are we talking about i don't know we
should share when we started liking
girls we can we can talk about that we
can yeah it's our lives i know but more
appropriately for today is uh something
we should be talking about yeah just the
karate element of that let's call it a
story for arguments okay um
who else plays karate i'll tell you who
our plays karate jesus christ
our guest today also did karate as a kid
in a movie called the karate kid ralph
macchio is our guest today are
distinguished you know for me this is uh
this this ticks a bunch of boxes in
terms of guests italian yup handsome yup
what else that's it okay those are the
those are my main boxes no it's uh
you know i watched his movies
religiously when i was a kid i what
karate kid was a seminal seminal
uh movie in my uh
childhood mine too yeah chronic kid
doesn't have to be simple for both of
you
it was maybe more for you i remember you
being really into it i loved it yeah but
like who did i didn't i know everyone
every kid and i'm sure most adults love
that movie that might be hard for young
all of them all three of them and some
like the fourth one with hillary swank
yes hopefully future guests hopefully um
yeah i mean great just so exciting and
the outsiders don't get me started on
ponyboy i've never seen it i'm ashamed
you should be my cousin vinnie of course
you've seen me love it love it um yeah
he is part and we talk about all three
of those um
formative
cinematic feats
uh we talk about them and what i find so
interesting now about ralph ralph oh
what up
that's his name oh yeah
oh uh-oh and that's uh-oh
you thought it was daniel larusso you
know maybe for a second you know what is
ralph machia it's the machio it's hard
for me to maybe i'm thinking of ray
fines it's not rave it's weird to call
ralph macho ralph it's weird to know him
maybe that's what it is it's very weird
to know him because you had never met
him and he seemed so familiar and you've
known of him did i speak your entire
life i i know i know and and his voice
his mannerisms his uh he was just so
familiar somebody i looked up to i mean
of course i looked up to the character
that he played every kid did it's so
weird and what's weirdest about
ralph's mr machio's uh
story his evolution as an actor is that
he now is being known he's widely known
now to a whole huge swath of people who
didn't who weren't familiar with him as
kids the way we were because he's on a
show now called cobra kai which is
the third season um
uh just premiered just honestly dropped
uh no uh it was the title shows drop i
don't know
it's on netflix yeah this jobs and this
podcast uh it's a great show it really
is great it's so good i just started
getting into it uh recently it is very
as they say bingeable it's bingeable and
watchable mm-hmm yeah and now he's
having this huge resurgence playing the
same character he played in the 80s
and uh you guys talk about that and i
want to hear about it let's do it let's
hear from him because there's so many
things i want to say but okay save it um
and you're about to hear from
i hate to call him daniel larusso
because he's so much more than that and
we talk about how much more and you're
about to find out how much more
my conversation with ralph macchio
iconic actor
in my life and many others coming up
right now life could be a dream
sweetheart
hello hello again shaboom in the book
we'll meet again
[Music]
my daughter is so
excited that i'm doing this podcast she
listens to you all no
big time she's a super fan from the
movies and everything else but uh ah
you're doing that one oh
well i'm glad what's her name uh julia
julia oh well thanks julia yeah yeah oh
i'm so glad i i i should tell julia that
i'm such a fan of your of her dad's i'm
uh
what does she think of that how does she
what does she think of your fame of
people knowing you and liking you the
way
you know you just mentioned
this and i'm geek dad you know it's it's
it yeah i think she well i will say this
much this project right now this this
cobra kai
what's happened with this show and
i never expected uh my kids
28 and 25 now which is just ridiculous
it's just oh my god the fact that i'm 29
i don't know how it's possible but no so
i i never expected
um them to
champion um be so um
uh just so proud of it share with their
my colleague my son was you know he's he
graduated uh from college since but the
first two seasons it was like watch
parties in the dorms and oh wow and
they're all they're all even this season
they're all back and forth you know just
watching it live on the phones together
and
is it kind of nice ralph for them to get
a taste of what you experienced uh
certainly in you know i see a poster of
the outsiders behind you in in the 80s
did you ever try to i mean not that you
would try to convey
how many people were aware of you and
what your fame you know
i think that's a great question i think
um what i wasn't expecting is is to have
the you know the joy of what
of which it feels to me right now to
have something that was so huge in my
life
yeah back in the day that is now so huge
in my house
today you know that's the most not not
too many people get that right you know
oh there's dad talking about that again
and now it's like
all of a sudden that cool subject you
know right right because karate kid must
be like they must have their frame of
reference it's funny to i'm now seeing
what's happened to you this resurgence
through their eyes a little bit and like
it it must have been
to them like oh there's a poster and
they've i'm sure they've seen the movie
but they probably couldn't at all
comprehend
how massive it was like i can't like i
remember i have a great story it was
like it's my son this is one of my
favorite stories my daughter is
julia is uh so she was i did a
musical how to succeed in business
without really trying oh sure
matthew broderick did it on broadway and
is 96 and i was i did the national tour
as the j pierpont finch it was really
loud so my daughter was four at the time
my son was a house plant then he we just
added water he was like little infant
child
and uh and so
you know we would go any city i would go
to we would have the the planet
hollywood press thing you know because
you're in a town for two weeks and you
do your press for the theater the
orpheum or wherever you are the fox
theater or whatever and when they'd
always have it in planet hollywood's and
then she started eight years old start
seeing this memorabilia up on the walls
if you remember where planet hollywoods
were yeah and uh and she asked like why
is why is daddy why are these these
pictures and everyone's standing on one
leg acting really weird and
every time they see daddy or telling him
that he stole a can of tuna fish or he
should stay cold
you know who is ponyboy who is ponyboy
and why haven't i met him you know i
mean so
so that was at the time that she sort of
you know then we have that five years
old we showed her not the outsiders that
was later and she read the outsiders in
school both my kids did
but my favorite story is my son when he
came i was like about four
maybe a little older
maybe maybe six he came out of the my
mom dropped off like a bin full of like
16 magazines and tiger beats and all
that stuff oh my god he came running in
the house
you know with like five of them in his
hands and he runs up to my door and he
says
jewel
dad was huge and we missed it
[Laughter]
that's great that's what answers your
question of what it is well yeah now
they're not
now they're not missing it it must have
but that must be so surreal to find
those magazines and like
i'm sure it was weird enough for you
having lived through it but like at
least with you it was like
it was incremental and it was like
i wha what was that like though ralph t
take me back like um what what and what
do you say to your kids like uh what
would you say in a podcast and how do
you explain that to your kids like those
magazines and that time in your life
that well now it's now it's easier since
they're a adult yeah but um
um
i don't i wish i had and this is when
you wish you could have that time stamp
and like go back in and watch the
footage of how i reacted to that yeah
yeah um but i think
i think um
you know i think to to to them
explaining sort of that
that time
um for me that time it's it's
interesting there's a window
you know because i got really fortunate
um when you look at um the outsiders and
and the karate kid and my cousin vinnie
those are kind of three films that
still hang in there oh god yeah yeah
they're they're on three of my favorites
all the time uh
and and so
it was a section of time
so you figure it's from six years of of
a chunk of time maybe a little bit
longer than that
that all that sort of happened for me
and um and i always explain i've even
talked to my kids about this have sort
of a unique existence
when and it's more with the daniel russo
character and it's changed slightly now
with the relevance of of cobra kai
and you know just being as big as it is
around the world but yeah
i would meet people
over the past 20 30 years and for the
most part the conversation would always
start
with where i was when
you know when i saw that movie you know
and so i i did you were like a
touchstone in people's lives but yeah
good better and different it's like you
know i wrote something for sports
illustrated um just a one-pager about
being frozen in time being
uh john wertheim was the is the um he's
on 60 minutes now he does stuff for them
but he's a great writer at si and he
asked me to write this piece on what
it's like
to
in essence be either the guy that threw
the touchdown pass and over time to win
the super bowl or the guy who missed
field goal in overtime and lost right
scott norwood yeah
the scott norwood or jim jim craig than
the
1980 hockey team and so i i wrote what
that's like because that it's i kind of
share that
i share a little bit of that being
associated with the character the people
remember where they were when they saw
the movie and there's a sports element
to it
um right so it's true i remember talking
to my kids about
about that and about that kind of
uniqueness when you're so associated to
to one thing and how to flip that to be
a positive and not like oh god this
again
yeah i mean you know obviously there are
countless examples of like how it you
know when it didn't turn out as well as
somebody what didn't have the foundation
that that you must have had but what
what do you attribute to your
remaining on your feet if you were ever
out in the ether of getting back on your
feet um
after that that that rush of fame
because it's not just it's it's also
just like that kind of notoriety must
have been that's i know it does
something to you psychologically and i
can't imagine at such an early age what
it does
how did you deal with that for me um it
was an early age but not as early as it
might have looked because of
my youthful appearance there i go
youtube yeah the fred gwen you
dad joke uh there'll be a few more i'm
sure but um
do people say that to you a lot are you
uh do they just say lines to you i mean
you mentioned the pony boy i imagine
that yeah
i get well because there are
catchphrases from those yeah well i mean
karate kids had to you know
from the sweep the leg to the you know
there's so much oh my god every time you
wash your car or wash anything publicly
i'm sure yeah yeah i have a very dirty
car i chose to never wash it
it's just like it's like why does your
car look like [ __ ] well because if i
pick up the sponge i gotta deal with
that and yeah yeah just big mud
collect or they do it for johnny's or
the or the uh oh yeah
you know
oh if you've ever been asked to sign
anything or anybody in your life named
johnny i'm sure
they yeah well it's interesting because
there's johnny lawrence who is the
nemesis in in the karate kid and now
cobra kai and and i played john yeah
i'll sign that signing the cans of tuna
for my cousin vinnie i've signed a few
cans of tuna like i shot the clerk with
a question mark
i shot the clerk
yeah i saw the club
you know it's kind of it's
you know it's a pop culture element that
of course oh my god i would probably be
one of those annoying people who
asked you to do something like that yeah
it's um
it's kind of the the thing that makes it
easier now or less of an eye roll
uh
that i might have had going on in the
90s when i wasn't you know when i was
what i call a lean years sort of
as far as an actor when i was doing more
writing and
jumping behind the camera and filming
you know making some shorts and raising
my kids
uh those were the times it was
um
um i was looking for
will this will i ever get out of this
tunnel
yeah
yeah but
i think
as the generation as the younger
generation has gotten older and i have
these 12 and 15 year old kids and
uh you know the outsiders alone i have
this so you run into these teenage girls
these 14 50 that still think
that we're like hot when we're like 60.
so
that where i get the eight-year-old kid
who wants to show me his crane kick on a
given tuesday and that makes it
then it's like it's bigger than anything
and it's sort of yeah that's where i
went from being like enough already and
i never was negative about it yeah but
it went from like okay this is tiring to
wow what a privilege
you know yeah and that i look at it
totally and just psychologically it must
be now that they're
now that this thing has really hit i
mean it's hitting like a crazy way it's
the number one show and
um
it must be
easier
not easier but but it you must
it just must be more palatable i guess
um
to deal with people coming up to you and
saying those lines but um
it's a kind of a a wonderful blessing
and and they say it is that
are you bothered every day and to me the
point not right now i mean we're in this
weird world where every day i'm pretty
much uh at home or at work
in some place uh i hope you're not
bothered by it at home yeah right no no
no by the postman
but uh you know it's
as you get older
um at least in my view
and i'd like to say wiser i don't know i
think i just embraced
i embrace uh
i have the opportunity to put smiles on
people's faces and make them feel
um
like a kid again this show i hear that
all the time i thank you for bringing
back my childhood thank you for making
me feel like i'm kidding now i just said
okay let's try this show let's see if we
can pitch it and sell it uh but i'm
looking really super smart right now but
it's really a it's a very
uh satisfying feeling
in our current world to
yeah sort of
of light and billy and i talk about the
zapkin and i talk about it i mean it's
just pretty wonderful to have that and
to be spreading that kind of joy based
on the revisiting of these characters
totally and i i had i had a similar
reaction to it because i was a kid when
i saw that and um it was a huge part of
my childhood as as was the outsiders and
vinnie and all those movies but i i
wonder
it's also the way you're doing it it's
such a smart way to examine
those characters and um
and you know we talk on the show it
comes up all the time you never really
know somebody you never know what
somebody's going through and
um you don't know their history when you
people talk about encounters they've had
that they regret or whatever the fights
they've been in and um that's what i
find so fascinating and so watchable
about your show now is that um it really
delves into these characters lives in a
way that like
amplifies that messages you never know
what somebody's
dealing with going through it's it's a
really special
it's a dive into the gray areas of these
characters i mean karate kid was clearly
a very black and white yeah like
storytelling right um you know
the russo was the underdog you rooted
for him the cobra kai is bad miyagi is
good
he's the human yoda to the young
skywalker and yeah it's very clear all
right yeah
where coped by your allegiance episode
episode could change and certainly in
the first season and leading into the
second larusso was set up a little more
as an antagonist for the to the johnny
lawrence redemption story and that was
what was fresh that's what was
um
interesting and the perspectives shift
and how the prism
it changes from whatever angle you're
looking at and that happens in the next
generation cast and those stories as
well
guys you know this is the writing this
is a john josh and hayden they
had their they were very specific about
that
well it's i mean that's not you of
course yeah but it's also uh you and
zapker are so good i mean you're just
the the acting too i think plays a big
part you you both must have been so
eager
especially it must have been what is
that like to have lived with this
character as just like a thing it's like
just a part of the noisier life you
mentioned that it talked about how your
kids
processed it but just strangers
what is it like to then just get to dive
in just like dig in as an actor to these
characters that was i mean
it's
it's both thrilling and terrifying at
the same time
um
um
terrifying to me only from this if it
failed
right
the franchise i never wanted to do this
because i didn't want to you know mess
with it um it has become bigger than me
the actor the film and that character he
was the every kid next door until we all
saw ourselves and he had no business
really winning anything which made us
all believe that we could
yeah well i always identified with
johnny but yeah most kids
i
think um
yeah it's true it's really sacred yeah
so we i the
so i was always very hesitant and bro
and certainly the last guy to come to
the party uh when when we're putting all
the pieces together i was you know they
had everything lined up and it was about
how to
you know and how to pitch a show called
cobra kai and a redemption story for
johnny and why i would go back and that
oh my god you know so it was a tough
they had a tall order and there were
three guys who wrote rated r comedies
like harold and kumar and harold yeah
those guys are yeah i know i remember
hearing about it
just from like a industry this is shop
talking but from that point of view i i
was so surprised to to hear that they
would that they were a part of something
like that
yeah and it was so for me um i knew
billy billy always over the years would
come to me say you know i think there's
more room for these carriages i mean but
anything he came to me with sounded
you know i said well you gotta who's
gonna
do it are you gonna write it or are we
gonna write i said i know i can't write
it i won't um it's too precious to me
i'd be too kid glovy with everything
um you know i have people crying coming
up to me with tears in their eyes this
character brought their
fathers and sons together so i had a
difficult time in school and daniel
russo made me feel
that i could overcome so i right so then
protection
i'm sure and then to do that at least
the pilot that first episode is like
larusso's kind of a dude he's turned
into like successes made him kind of
douchey that must have been
that must have been weird it was weird
that was great that was the tough part
for me because we i mean we shot all
you know the whole season was picked up
so we had 10 episodes yeah youtube and
uh and so you know yeah there was a
negotiation with the writers because
i said
you know i knew what you need i said i
know what you need
because you have to have this guy so
down and out meaning johnny lawrence go
sleeping in the dirt you gotta push him
yes she didn't even have a
turtle and rocky at least had a turtle
he had nothing
right
no friend no life
so how could we make larusso
everywhere he turns it's the exact the
happily ever after on the billboards
yeah you know so i got the perspective
it was about negotiating okay how to add
a human side to that so it doesn't
become
um a one-off or one joke idea and they
they they had their finger on that pulse
the whole way it was just about me
swallowing it when i say i kicked his
face it was like that was the line that
i knew as soon as i say that line it's
immediately an antagonist because it's a
it's kind of a dickman
yeah and then there's bread earns those
guys are great
and i love bread so so the that whole
section
knowing that scene
um the whole point for me was like i
have to give him a car for free like
that was my and then
i said the whole thing is he's like he's
saying it because you gotta remember
he's looking at a guy to beat the crap
out of him and surrounded him five on
one
and uh true you know and
uh you know
so he had he had reason
he had a
yeah there's a little in there it's it's
a really you're right ralph it's a
really delicate balance it's a fine line
to walk you don't want to
but i knew where we were going and so
when we get into season two and
certainly season three now
um diving into the origins of of miyagi
dough and the trip to okinawa and and
re-teaming with some great guest stars i
mean guest stars on the show but but you
know legacy characters from the films
and elizabeth shue and tamlin tamita and
and
moto so they're all
so cool
they're there and it's so there's a
richness and now it's really a it's
about it's balance between uh larusso
and lawrence as far as protagonists
antagonists it's always been that but at
the onset of the show
um it clearly was set up the johnny
lawrence
you know redemption story and but creed
had just come out the original creed
um
i think they did a sequel but i didn't
see the sequel but um and so that was
that was out in theaters when cobra kai
was pitched which was helpful to i bet
yeah
to them
because if it wasn't i wouldn't have
known
can you go into can you go into the
world of rocky balboa or through the
eyes of
the the the villain's son if you will
and then what does that story become and
it worked very well
and uh that that only um
added to my confidence that if well
executed this is a smart way in where
you're not trying to tell
that story of where's daniel russo and
his his house and then where is miami is
no longer there and
yeah
in that this is okay how could we back
into that and then bill it's interesting
it's
yeah but it's both it's it's redemption
about somebody who has found and it
helps
who hasn't defined success and who has
this um certainly the ideal looking
family and all that it's i just think
it's so rich um in terms of
not only exploring the down and out
character but um yeah somebody who was
successful from that story
and now they both get to
um
you know you see
you see the loss and on the daniel
arussa side you see his
um they're less demons but they're more
character flaws
um and and his
his knee-jerk
temper that he had in the original film
that only gets amplified by
a guy without his
mentor who
focuses going through a midlife crisis
is
you know as dealing with the you know um
the responsibility
of uh of trying to pass on the teachings
of his master and what's just because
you know
the lesson doesn't mean you know how to
teach it you know right and how
important it it also
amplifies how important miyagi's
presence was and it's really
heartbreaking
early on in the series when he's looking
at um a clip i think where you you just
miss
also just missing that guy then you miss
i'm sure for you it's a hundred fold
missing
um yeah that would be magic that was
magic m and i it was just
was one of those uh things that it was
just so easy
uh to work with him i think you know
usually this happens the right actors
usually get the part you know
and in this case the right actors got
the parts
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello ralph at the time was it like was
it coming off of um because rob lowe was
on here talking about it was i had no
idea this is how the coppola cast the
outsiders i didn't know he had like a
list of
like little like heartthrobs um
teen heartthrobs uh
but then of course that movie was huge
and
was was the karate kid
was that a difficult audition process
was that like
um did everybody
want that or was it you had this success
coming off of the outsiders what
happened with the outsiders was i mean
rob probably explained it was it was
kind of brutal coppola had everyone in
the same studio you were just like you
read with dennis quaid and you read with
swayze mickey rourke which reads with
ralph and
yeah sit down okay now you play so and
so and what well he said the cool one
everybody wanted rumblefish he said that
was like the cooler one oh yeah but the
rumblefish wasn't on this time rumble's
fish was
not on the on the books is being made at
that audition at the other time the
outsiders when you were shooting the
outsiders and they were deciding to make
rumble fish now we're all fighting to
get into rome oh weird oh my god you
know i remember speaking of fred russo
the coppola's longtime producer and
essentially the one who cast the
outsiders and american graffiti um so uh
he
we spoke about i think vincent spano
played the part that i was
considered for
but um oh i can see that yeah yeah oh
wow but to to answer your question the
karate kid i went into john appleson's
apartment in new york city i heard that
you know i read the script and i saw the
title and i said this is just the
cheesiest silliest
title ever maybe i i was on fallon last
night saying maybe it was foreshadowing
uh that i thought if i ever got the
party i'd have to carry the damn thing
for the rest of my life
but uh um
so i went to abelson's apartment and it
was just him
the hallways were lined with actors
everybody uh
it wasn't like i had a specialty
treatment
oh my god and i walked past the poster
of like rocky and save the tiger which i
love jack lemmon film and and uh there
was john abelson in his little back
office with a big jvc kind of camera and
the battery pack and
this video you could watch on youtube if
you put it in there ralph launcher
memory audition
uh pat maria was who did his audition
separately but this you could check it
out after the thing you could watch oh
i'm reading live with avelson um
and he's remember the scene yeah it was
the uh
uh after
la russo wakes up after the beat down at
the the skeleton beat down at the fence
and miyagi is you
know he's questioning who he is and what
and uh
um you know he learns who miyagi the
maintenance man was saved him and
now he wants them to teach him karate
you know that's the jcpenney 398 you
know what kind of yeah
yeah and it was it was just john reading
with me and uh
kind of at the end of it he
you know gives you a little glimpse of
um i can't guarantee anything but i
would consider his taking some karate
lessons which never happens
you know he was basically saying you
know you're you're a good actor i
remember he said you're a good actor and
i was like and it was weird he almost
said it
with a surprise and he's surprised yeah
who knew i was just okay i walked in
with my members only jacket and it's
just oh my god
was it
it's it's yeah and you said every all
the other kids were lined up in the in
the hallway you must have you you must
have passed by guys that you knew you
must have
yeah there were a couple
um i remember john cryer being there
that day oh
i i
and uh this is before you know no
his big success on television and
everything else but i had known him from
new york theater
but um
um it's it's interesting it was uh
i can't remember like new york guys at
that age i guess like
like broader matthew broderick or fisher
stevens you're like fisher i've known i
wonder if you've ever read i'm sure they
all
yeah my and my time slot uh you know
because it was just his apartment and uh
weird and then from there he called me
back in to read with uh with some
actresses for ally
um
and elizabeth shu that's where i met her
and that that footage too is on youtube
you get oh my god i i can't believe i
didn't oh
daniel with an l
all that stuff that happened in an
improv
you could watch that live uh later today
it's really how wilson kept all that
stuff and before he passed away asked if
he could
put it up and he enjoy
uh responding with the fans commenting
about it no way that's cool i was so
funny i i it's funny you mentioned
auditions on youtube because the one
that i think i'm thinking of now related
to you is um
i've i've always wondered if you've seen
this and i forgot to ask uh
rob and matt dillon i've worked with
i've never asked him about it because i
figured the answer was no but um did you
ever see brian a teen
yes the brian yeah yeah oh my first time
numerous times
what um
what do you think about that yeah it was
just so
it's that was the uh oh my god i
remember franco i was i i did this uh i
did the deuce on hbo franco oh yeah
great david simon show and
yeah and uh and he brought that up too
many actors i bet i bet
and he i think he even had it on his
phone in between takes the deuce at
three in the morning when we're shooting
in the like times square in the
seventies and
uh well one show to do it's it's it's
interesting so for those of you who
don't know brian tina's he's a guy who
auditioned for i think juilliard yeah i
think he got in
it's great i think i didn't put it but
it's this really big audition but it's
funny and but then afterwards they cut
to um
you doing the scene you do when you're
on your deathbed and it's like you know
the thing that struck me about that um
is it it just reminds you how how good
you are how how good of an actor you are
thank you first of all thank you that
that
you put
when you
decide you know when it's separated
so
yes he was going for a different thing
dramatic yeah but the uh
the
the outsiders is one of my favorite uh
roles i ever played one of my
favorite performances i think because i
mean i certainly was invested very
invested in it um i read the book when i
was 12. it was um i connected to it
essiens or writing a 16 year old girl
wrote that book
you know and and i
um johnny cave was just the part i
wanted um i know i i think downey jr i
think he did the workshop
who was also a candidate for daniel
russo
at the early stages i was winning those
battles and then later on years
the iron man the hell
yeah he's so talented he's just sick
talented um but uh
um
oh god i lost my train of thought where
were we but but when he did so he had he
had done the table read or the the
workshop oh yeah so i was talking about
it so the outside is the reason why i'm
so proud of that performance is is um
and and and some of this is due to
coppola and him
sort of stripping away uh stuff and
keeping me um
not editing myself which often i do
sometimes
more results oriented and process
oriented and sometimes you have to let
go of trying to get to that result than
just letting the process
uh play out and he he taught me or at
least he opened that up for for me to
just allow
the behavior to happen
just to be more present ralph like to
not
and just be
i think the scene
that i would uh allude to the most is in
the at the end of the film when
ponyboy's reading if you recall he reads
the letter after johnny dies and you see
a superimposition of me and dylan as
dallas and johnny and i'm just reading
the words uh you know of of the letter
that he is
if you you hear me yes and and when we
were shooting that francis i was
i guess i was reaching if you will it
was early on and he just kept wanting me
just
re you know let it go relax and just
it's the most honest one of the most
honest pieces of film i've ever
been in there's a few of them in other
places yeah really is truly honest and i
think that the the performance of johnny
kate is honest i mean it's like uh you
know
in the karate kid there a moment like
that is when i say to pat maria you're
the best friend i ever had
it's
[Music]
goosebumps so those those are the
moments that i take the most pride in
and that are
you know it takes work to get it takes
work to let go of it all yet to get
totally and it's hard
for people to understand that yeah
so ralph well just because i'm such a
geek about this stuff and i love coppola
so much and i've seen some
behind-the-scenes stuff of him i love
watching him in action um
he
i love the way he speaks to actors but
how would you
articulate that like what would he say
to you to strip that away to to get out
of your head and
did you like a bad impression what he
did what he he would say when i one of
the things that the outsiders we did a
bunch of
um sense memory exercises we had two
weeks of basically an acting camp but
the greasers were kept in one area the
socials were kept in another
so she's had like leather-bound scripts
and
and hotel rooms high up on the floor so
you couldn't hang out with diane lane
yeah that we couldn't we couldn't get
near everybody that sucks yeah
so fantastic
but he uh one time he just looked at me
said you're too long island you're two
um you're two
he said you need i'm gonna give you here
we're gonna give you you take five
dollars and you spend the day and you
find a way for that to feed you and
spend the night out on the street and uh
you know how it's like
what part of my brain's like call the
agent the other part of my brain is this
is awesome
yeah yeah that's funny
and um i literally slept outside
um you know close to the hotel they kind
of knew i was there on sort of this
bench to try to get comfortable and not
and it was cold and just to not
have a place
to go
which john were you in tulsa right
tulsa oklahoma and johnny did not have a
place to go hang on one second
wow that is so cool
johnny did not have a home to go to and
i always did and i you know i was just
yeah um so
so i uh i slept outside that night with
newspapers on as my oh my you know like
in the script um to try to stay warm and
incidentally
newspapers don't work
okay
um
and um
and then i just i took you know i just
bought some food and went to a 7-eleven
and was like whoa okay if i have this
for lunch
how am i going to make this for you and
i just did that for you yeah not 24
hours but
uh you know
um probably like a midday till then then
next morning i mean as soon as the sun
as soon as it got a little bright i was
right back in my hotel and i said okay i
get it
i did i yeah okay
i'm gonna use it i'll use it no no but
it was um another thing here's another
good one he said to me
i was doing a scene uh
and he said i want you to
not play the darkness of it and that's
also in my audition and on the dvd
extras but he used this when i was
shooting the film he said
don't play how bad things are for him i
want you in the scene to be thinking
about
even though the dialogue doesn't support
this
i want you to be thinking about the one
day your parents your dad took you to
say an equivalent of disneyland and it
was a great day and i want you to have
the feeling of that day
when you're playing the scene even
though the scene was like about the
socials and him having some uh
i don't remember exactly what this
specific dialogue of the scene was but
it was sort of like you know it was it
was the left hand it was the left-handed
side of looking at it um because what he
was trying to do i see it now is not
play into the negative and the darkness
and the internet so smart terrible you
know and another time he also said he
said once he's um he said take a rock
i'm going to hand you a rock right now
and put it in your pocket the jean
pocket of johnny kid because he always
walked around with his hands
and
he says and and during the scene instead
of thinking about
what you're saying i want you to try to
figure out what color that rock is
oh it's so smart yeah it was basically
he was tossing me uh get out of your
head yeah get out of your head basically
yeah and and um and it wasn't like i had
to do this was every day these were just
three examples i could give you
of stuff that he would do and certain
actors embrace that and other actors
that like get out of my [ __ ] you know i
mean you know some people
uh some are more malleable
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah
some stuff you do have to find uh
yourself but there's since you're a big
couple of geek guys those are a few uh
tidbits i can give you that that are
really well that's correct that's so
cool ruff it's also not just coppola but
like you guys are all so
there's such good performances in in
those movies such great teen
performances you like you said you're
you're you're all just so honest and um
i'm thinking about that scene now that
the bryan a teen scene where you're just
it's just there's some there's a real
truth that you're accessing and it makes
sense that you felt such a connection to
it you know
i did and that day in the hospital that
whole day i stayed in that sort of it's
the parallel
i stayed there i ate there i didn't you
know i um
i had to go to the bathroom i guess i
don't recall but uh i really tried to i
was at that young i just wanted to be
awesome in that movie yes yes
essie hinton classic novel it's the best
part in the movie
you know or one of
and yeah oh my god at least leave it
all out there i remember i did an acting
class um i took an act and i said uh
study at the beverly hills playhouse and
i brought the scene in
um
that scene that you know wow um in the
hospital uh for a scene study just to
before i ever got the part oh my god out
of the book you know it was and how old
were you ralph when you when you did
that were you oh when i was in the
acting class that was um when i did the
i i was 19 when i shot um on the other
side so you got to end the machio curve
you got to take five to seven years off
yeah mine is the same thing yeah you got
that thing too and you do it as long as
you can i was playing a high school a
college student when i was 27 28. um
yeah wait wow so but you just loved um
and you struck me as somebody who always
just loved
acting you you weren't like you don't
never seem like a quote unquote child
actor like one of those precocious like
hello there my name is ralph
yeah yeah yeah i never i never went
the truth is i didn't start studying it
um and not that i've studied
been in acting classes for decades on
end
but i didn't
kind of pay my dues or
until after i had my initial success i
mean i just got the parts
but i got there there felt like a time
where i it's so funny because
a lot of years after that it didn't feel
this way but the time i felt like i when
i walked in the room i was just it's
almost like i couldn't not get it
yes it was a little window of time
the first movie i did i went i did this
movie called up the academy robert
downey senior directed
oh wow and um that was my first movie
and then i did this show called eight is
enough and then
for a year
um and then um and then the outsiders
was the big you know the big street cred
break and then the karate kid so all
that just i would just go in and either
be a finalist or get the part and then
after that
it became uh
uh tougher and i started um you know
i mean i i well
during that i'm gonna see my memory is
getting a little blurred but during that
time
after eight is enough before the
outsiders is when i started to study it
take some classes because when the
outsiders were on the books i said okay
i'm not going to get by anymore looking
quasi-cute hitting the mark and saying
sure i'll have some mom you know that
was that i guess and i kind of felt that
that was going to run out of gas but
i paid my dues
after all that initial success through
even the karate kitted stuff because
that's when it dried up and that's when
you know i had to scratch and claw a
little more yeah after even after my
cousin vinnie even before my cousin
vinnie that started
you started to feel that mike hasn't
been not an easy yet we had a it wasn't
i had a fight to get in the room
no kidding of course i was off the list
if you will right you know how that
works
yeah and what but what what why like
what do you attribute that to i mean
yeah there had been two sequels to
karate kid it was it was it was being so
associated with the karate kid
yeah that was clearly the word from the
studio uh 20th century fox at that time
and uh
is um you know i knew joe pesci because
i did a play with de niro on broadway
called kubernetes teddy bear and it was
a big
deal in the summer of 86 and joe
i was we did it at the public theater
for a few months and then at the long
acre for a couple of uh
uh months and it was the you know ticket
in town and so i knew pesci and
i knew he was in it and and uh but the
studio is like nah he's the you know
he's a they told jonathan lynn the
director
at that time was basically no you don't
he's the karate kid we don't want him
you know you're just gonna see that
you're gonna have
and uh which is the uh ironically what i
felt when they brought pat maria in for
the karate kid i'm like oh arnold from
happy days this is gonna be terrible ah
it's kind of fun i'm actually writing
something about that right now just the
conceptual you know the preconceived
notions of who you think an actor is and
and totally yeah but um
[Music]
but it makes sense i mean it's lame and
it's it must have been really
frustrating but like
that movie i remember i mean i was i was
watching i was falling in love with
movies during that time that was such a
uh
seminal i mean it was just a massive
hit that like it it makes sense it's not
right but um
yeah i can't understand it
it was funny because um
uh at that point it was like they were
looking at will smith and ben stiller
why
because they were both
right at the cusp of breaking out right
and i was you know arguably on the other
side of that hill at the moment as far
as a young actor yeah yeah
and uh and will smith actually came in
to read when i finally got in the room
to read for vinnie he was one of the
actors i read
and he's oh he's one of the executive
producers on cobra kai
that's i saw that i saw that and there
was a pinkett in there
how did that happen how did they find
did you have you reminded him of that
that uh
yes
well
here's the thing the reason why over
brook and and uh which is will smith's
company and and caleb uh pinkett are our
eps on the show is because when jerry
weintraub the original producer of the
karate kid
allowed the remake the james smith
jackie chan remake
i guess they made a deal with uh
overwrook that they assumed some of the
rights going oh
that's right in order for john josh and
hayden are great writers and creators of
cobra kaido
they had to get sony pictures they had
to get jerry weintraub productions they
had to get overbrook they had to get all
those ducks in a row so that's you do a
jerry weintraub impression oh jerry what
are you kidding he used to call me the
kid that bought him a couple of houses
that's that's good
that makes sense i mean i loved you i
missed somebody yeah you couldn't help
but love the guy you know he got i would
say this title this karate kid title and
he would like
it's a terrible title which makes it a
great title
but that's strange
that's really good and that's real jerry
weintraub wisdom and which is like
that's kind of true yeah that's true
that's such a my favorite is is when we
walked out of seeing the sneak preview
of the karate kid and everybody was
doing the crane kick on the street on
second avenue oh my god he just put his
arm around me he said we're gonna be
making a couple of these
that's what
oh my god that's what he knew
right well when people walk out of your
movie and they're doing the move
you know or they're running up the side
of the steps like rocky you have a
feeling you might be making more than
one
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
did you know i mean like as a young
actor then you're walking out with this
hollywood producer
and you see that happening the kid's
doing the kick did did how did that feel
i mean did you have any that was an idea
it was an amazing um
uh an amazing experience that night
because i hadn't seen the movie
and um wow
and so i i on second avenue second and
twelfth or eleven marinette coronet the
baronet card oh yeah 59th
um
so it was a it was a sneak preview on
the days where they would have sneak
previews with like real ticket buyers
you know
yeah and they still i mean they don't do
that now but um but it was when you know
and it was a month before the movie was
coming out and i
you know it was just i walked in sort of
like a guy a couple people might have
recognized from uh the outsiders and i
walked out as like everybody's brother
that they were just cheering
uh
it was uh
um
as is one of those moments in my life
that is that is
is mine all mine kind of a thing it's
yeah
very few people share that experience
because i had only heard that the film
was
uh good and and i didn't
you know i was in a virtually almost
every frame of the darn thing and people
liked it when you're a young actor
you can't conceptualize what that's like
you know
that i grew up rocky was my childhood
movie you know i ran up the steps all
the time and i would play the you know
the bill conti soundtrack and then
incidentally bill conti did the you know
the music and the karate kid and it's
still beautiful
oh it's like a score to that movie and
so
it's how close was your childhood to now
i'm picturing rocky and and i know you
grew up in how italian was your
upbringing
not that not that italian oh really we
were pretty americanized we're like
third generation so it wasn't like my
parents came off the boat or even my
grandparents came off the boat it was my
great grandpa so it was
and uh and for whatever reason my dad
cannot stand garlic
he clay oh no way my brother as well so
you're kidding
so we didn't have that you walk in the
house and you have that isn't that funny
oh my
god my dad's half greek
um so i have a
maternal my paternal grandmother so uh
the mediterranean blend um i proud
my wife's parents were more with the
gravy on sunday and the seven fishes on
christmas eve and
we were a little i mean we followed
certain of those traditions but it
wasn't like uh oh isn't that funny ralph
what's house
i just totally i mean we're talking
about making assumptions up about people
i i
would totally have assumed that you were
traditional the seven course fished
catholic really uh
wow that's funny and
you had siblings you grew up with
siblings yeah my brother my one brother
uh he's a little younger than i am
totally different path in his life and
uh
um he's he's doing well um and uh
did he ever have ambitions to be an
actor like were your parents and did
your parents ever were they like how how
into you being an actor were that it's a
big question that's a great question my
mom i grew up
watching what was called the 430 movie
on channel 11 in new york and they were
all the mgm musicals
um and i grew up you know coming home
from pool my mom would have this singing
in the rain or you know whatever was was
on uh television i would that would be
the my milk and cookie time after i got
home you know so yeah jean kelly as a
kid she wanted to be
uh my mom wanted to be betty grebel like
you know in her time so she feel felt
like she never
got to do that
she's so funny ralph she did not stage
mother me and put me into uh you know
theater class at all i never felt that
bush but i asked can i do what gene
kelly does he's so cool wow
handsome so i took some dance lessons
and i was in the theater at school and i
would go to the musicals and i'd love
that stuff
dad was a little bit like
you know i think concerned as you're
five and six year old five six seven
eight but then i was but i was also what
are you doing i was at every met game i
was at that game dare i say
oh no i you're talking to a oh i thought
i had my shirt on
no
same mets and chads yeah that's jets and
i'm a big islander fan and that was that
was our hockey team uh and i won four
stanley cups in the 80s so
i would play little league street hockey
and then uh and tap dance
oh okay so there's a balance that's how
balance all about balance is uh as
miyagi would say for to you
yeah wow okay so um i'm getting a note
that we got i'm so s i i for the record
i could i could do this for you know
it's like the way dogs just will eat
until they
throw up i could i could just talk to
you for a long time so um but i'm
getting a note that we gotta
hurry it along there's one other thing
though um
so it was it was okay dance that's
interesting um
but so your mom was into it she was into
it but she wasn't like pushing she was
not pushy in any way
but she was into it my dad
recognized that i shined you know so he
was i give him credit for not saying
you're not going to put my son he was
not that kind of
uh you know overly macho thing but but
i'm sure there were moments where he
said
are we sure about this
uh but he uh he they couldn't be more
proud
when you're doing jazz hands at shea
stadium pass the salt
yeah
yeah
kenny o'brien he's my man
um
okay well we have like a lightning round
uh
this is so bright from the jet oh kenyo
man by the way yeah
how do you feel about um the last couple
of games it's like god they can't even
they can't even
lose when they're supposed yeah i know i
listen i you know you you play to win
the game and that's what it is i mean i
if you're a player i feel like they're
going out there i know uh you know i
wasn't i wasn't disappointed that they
i don't like the setup with the draft
that did i know you get out just to get
the number one i think there's
manipulation but then you look at the
eagles what they did and it's like i
wouldn't want them to do that yeah yeah
yeah i don't i don't love the way it's
set up that way but uh you know every
every new season i'm like it's all full
of hope like the mets right now full of
hope islanders on their way up i think
the jets will rebound in some way
um yeah yeah we i yeah really been in my
brother was we were big big fans um and
what about basketball nicks uh nix i my
son worked for the nets for a little
while so
you know he was working in data
analytics for the
the brooklyn nets now he's working for
the nhl um so he's a little bit of a
chip off the old block as far as uh
sports not the math he's got the math
mind thank god uh my daughter
my daughter is a dancer singer actress
she's fantastic and your biggest fan um
so man
yeah she did the national tour of uh
flash dance in the jennifer beale's
role
talking to the guys about that somehow
oh yeah my god that would be fun that
would be great that's so nice and it's
weird it's weird i mean she and i'm so
glad now they're getting to see you
um have the kind of success the level
that you had in the 80s and 90s and
it's really nice i've always been such a
huge fan of yours i uh it's it must be
nice for them to see that
get to witness it yeah um
it is nice
random weird question you're talking
about these actors that you came up with
uh jerry o'connell are you did you ever
cross paths with sherry i i uh did i
what with jerry what are you saying did
you cross paths with him he was in new
york actually
once we did a uh we did something in the
hamptons
at the uh guild hall we did uh celebrity
autobiography together
oh i love that show
in new york oh really that's triad
theater and i've never done it out west
where are you now you're at west i'm in
connecticut now so
yeah you're a ferry boat
across and come up and visit you're in
long island on a long island
oh hey i didn't i
mean
i'm right across the on one ferry boat
away and now i know where to find you go
over to go to port chef and and see you
guys uh
um
that's cool man okay well
jerry i just that's the only time i've
ever met him i remember you know i
followed his career i mean i say i've
seen stand by me like 12 times in the
theater uh when that came out during
that time and watched him and then i
don't know when he came then when he was
no longer that little chubby kid i was
like holy crap i mean this is the
transformation
yeah yeah i know i know you guys just
have similar
you remind me as kids of one another
similar like fearlessness you're talking
about those auditions and jerry would
say
a similar thing yeah i just did it i you
know every time i had not there was just
something um
very odd it's so rare that kind of
acting as a kid uh
yeah i i just i'm curious um sorry rob i
got uh lightning round i'm getting that
my second one oh boy i'm sorry and
i think you gotta quit okay here we go
what's this what is your most uh this is
i hate following up an apology with what
is your most commonly used emoji would
you say
uh right now a thumbs up because oh no
well not true right now it's it's it's
the
it's uh
it's probably the strong arm and the
karate ghee
oh yeah oh good for in reference now you
know
on netflix i mean that's everybody's
saying it's awesome love the show it's
great i'm so happy and i just keep
sending the strong arm with the karate
key because that's
those are the two
it's very appropriate you know so um
that may change uh yeah
yeah um
if you could depending on the next
project maybe um
if if you could if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
i think it would be baseball
um that's a good question um i love when
i was a kid it was a a hockey i wanted
to be the guy who like in over time
would skate single-handedly around the
entire team and score that uh so that
was that but i think baseball
i think i'd love to be that pitcher
um who is able to come in
and just get it done just lock it down
not necessarily the guy in his knees
goliath i want to make his knees buckle
at the plate yeah
yeah like uh
killer bugs bunny screw ball that just
makes
you know to be brought in you know the
bottom of the knife whatever two on base
is loaded and you have babe ruth up
there and you somehow
just the power to say i'm gonna take
this ball and there's no way you're
going to be able to hit it
that would be cool well i'm thinking of
you as a kid going in those rooms
because that to me requires a lot of
like a stealiness that like
i don't know if i've ever had as an
actor where i can go into an audition
and just i'm gonna get there's there's a
level of fearlessness that i think that
requires i had that when i was younger i
lost that honestly and in
full transparency i mean certainly when
roles didn't start to happen
then it became that very unhealthy
desperate okay now i i gotta get this
and that changes the timeline
totally it's day and night
isn't that amazing and they can sense it
i mean it must like reek yeah yeah um
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
oh wow
i'm going kitkat right now i don't know
why it's it's it's winty it's just
but
you know not too it has to be cool
so it's got a little snap
yeah you don't want any mushiness you
don't want it in the pocket i just had
um there was a kitkat for help this past
halloween uh that had a marshmallow
flavor which sounds gross but um
i recommend if you can find them in the
store a marshmallow flavored kit kat
it's white and delicious
who was the biggest on the outsiders
you're going i'm thinking of matt dillon
i guess
you know matt i know enjoyed a night out
who was who was the guy who was like
come on let's do it
um
it's it's funny because there was a
everyone had their
day in the sun of being that guy
probably yeah each of which was me and i
think rob lowe said he would buy me a
t-shirt that said do not disturb because
that's what always been on my door i was
studying my lines i wanted
over serious about
being awesome
and i needed i think that's why coppola
was giving me those little pieces of
just loosen up stop thinking yeah
yeah they wanted to be so great that
sometimes eager away you know um
you know there were times cruz was that
guy there was times swayze was that guy
um you know i had uh
matt was you know matt was a little
different because matt and i've remained
friends with him over over the years
he's done some play readings with with
me and we've hey man amen yeah he's like
he's uh he's like he likes my
he's so funny he was eager yeah he's so
funny
debbie
and i want to hear your mat i feel like
you have a man i don't have a great
one time we were doing the scene in the
back seat he's i'm eating all the
barbecue stuff with ponyboy and he's
like when we get to a hideout a hangout
a hideout or whatever he's like um you
know you think you think my uh father
would care about me oh no no they don't
give me crap about me or nothing and uh
we would do he would couldn't remember
these lines um because they were tough
he had a lot of lines and i i worked
with him and that those impressions are
not the ones i'm doing i'm leading to
the one that i know how to do
it's when i went to his hotel room and i
ran the scene
with him right down the hallway and we
ran it over and over and over because we
had to go back in and finish it up we
never finished it that to me he goes you
you're the most professional actor i've
ever worked with
at 18 that's what he said
and to this day to this day
i didn't know what that meant i was like
professional i was just running along i
just wanted to get done with the scene
but we uh i think we have a mutual
respect in that way
i
i love his ability to be his raw and
just you know have that yeah have that
star element about him at such a young
age and and to be to ad-lib and try and
not totally be in the book all the time
and he did that with dallas and i was
more i had his lines my lines and the
next guy's lines memorized and so yeah
wow
he must have been
you know yeah he i remember him saying
to me a similar thing you said which is
after you know when he did out to the
outsiders just like he he would say you
know france just knew i was that guy man
he just
he knew i was like i said there's the
idea that you know he didn't have to
really
work i mean what i mean
not not to dismiss what he did in it but
but like so he said he started studying
after that movie i mean he
really concentrated on i wonder if it
was
having worked with you now um no who
knows maybe a little bit i hope i hope i
rub off for some bit of pause i love
matt i really do i mean
i've had a script once and i was talking
to him about playing a part and it never
it came in fruition but he did come and
do a reading of it for me and you know
something i wanted to direct that never
came to fruition but he uh
he i said i send it to francis too he
goes be careful friends he's a script
nazi
he's gonna send it back it'll shoot up
and spit out
oh wouldn't you love to
have witnessed matt getting the script
back from what is this man with all the
notes oh god that's funny um ralph
what's your favorite movie sequel of all
time you pick one movie sequel
wait say this again sorry brother your
what's your favorite movie sequel of all
time um
that's a good one i mean godfather two
is is the easy answer
but you know in a
weird way uh in the in the more poppy
popcorn way i would say terminator two
oh yeah i just remember seeing that the
liquid man thing and how the technology
and that right mind-blowing it just it's
just
ah i i don't think people
sound so old now but at the time it was
like mind-blowing
um what's your go-to karaoke song
i i don't i mean i don't know i don't i
don't know okay you carry on that's okay
uh your first celebrity crush
probably ann margaret in bye bye birdie
oh yeah oh great yeah isn't she my
favorite i hit the brain fart what's the
matter with kids
you go with that you're going paul what
was it paul that was my first crush
um
i think she wasn't bye-bye birdie i i
hope so candace
early candice bergen awesome but i know
it was definitely it was definitely ann
margaret
and bye bye birdie uh
um and and there will be marilyn monroe
430 movie on channel 11. on channel 11
sure wpix was that wpi
uh if you had if you had to get a tattoo
i don't know if you have them um or if
you had to get another one where where
what would you get and where where would
it be or what would it be
who are both
um
i'm not a tattoo guy
uh but
i would probably
i
i don't get the ankle tattoos i'm going
over i'm trying to see what what this
would be i'll tell you this much
i
have um seen
many and have been asked to write stay
gold
on
people
and i've written it and they've gotten
it tattooed and since that was the first
big break movie role of my life it would
be stay gold and i would probably
probably put it oh i don't know i
couldn't put it on a bicep because then
it would get lost now
you know these things uh
i don't know shoulder back of the
shoulders something like that
yeah i'll make it paint maybe the taint
yes
um
yeah uh if you uh oh your favorite fruit
what's your favorite fruit nice ripe
piece of
um um honeycrisp apples
right now oh i just had one they're in
season now
apples man
yeah
uh and uh who would you want to play you
in a biopic in the ralph macchio story
oh my
gosh uh i never you know i've never
given uh a thought to that
my god
maybe i should have show
from uh from our cobra kai show he said
he's sort of like the millennial daniel
russo he may be a good yeah a good uh
ralph you know because for years i
toyed around with trying to find the
right script to do the salminio story
um because oh my god that's right i've
read that so you guys
oh my god you're perfect you know johnny
and the outsiders there were a lot of
reviews that were saying a young
salminio and you know
without a cause and some of those other
films and his life story is just so dark
and fascinating um yeah but i regret not
that never coming to because now too
much time has gone by um um because
but uh
that is a role
that's a role that is not that it got
away it never i mean i know franco made
a film called sal but it was that was
not it was a little bit uh different but
that was something
um
i've spoken i even spoke to coppola uh
about that you know we're trying to it's
about fine you know it's just one of
those things sometimes they come
together sometimes they don't yeah yeah
um
uh dogs or cats do you prefer dogs not
even clothes
uh-huh
uh and the beetles are the rolling
stones
well i'll go beetles even though my wife
will kill my wife and such a stuff i
love both because the blues oh really
it's infused into the stones that's a
tough that's a that's i know sorry
and and uh and you're you're watching tv
seinfeld is on and friends is on
what do you want
yeah would you have a favorite birth
both any day but seinfeld
yeah do you have a favorite episode one
that jumps out oh i'd like to see that
one um
um
god i remember watching mastermind my
domain i remember watching that myself
by myself
and
i just you know it was just pure
perfection
so perfect yeah it's the fastball down
the middle um but that's yeah no
for a reason uh i remember seeing with
my parents unfortunately and i was you
know
13 14. i was right around the time when
i was becoming
trying to be master of my domain um
and and ralph what what are um what are
two adjectives that you would want
people to use to describe you
after you've gone um
this was a little morbid i know but if
you could think of two you know it's
something you'd want if you could
witness your own eulogy
genuine
because i try to be
oh this is hard man i know it's not a
good lightning round there's a million
of them i'm trying to i know i know i'm
trying to do i'm listening to the
coppola tell me to get out of my head
so i would say
genuine
and positive they're lame but
no
i know it's so late i was mentioning
those two things when they were talking
about me
that i was uh
positive and genuine i think uh that's
that's not a terrible
uh thing to spread
yeah yeah well um you you've definitely
striked me as both and i'm so happy for
all the the success now and uh the
show's so good and you've just been such
a pleasure to talk to you thanks best to
you and uh thanks for the support man
so that so that happened so that
happened
new york he's a little serious that's a
little too sopranos yeah maybe but you
know can't you see him on that he's got
this great i love that that new york
kind of cop he's such a guy he's a guy
yeah he's got this real
he's i know you don't say that
but he really is he's such a guy he's
not a woman
no but he's but i know he's a man but
you can't use it as a you can't say
you you can't i know what you're saying
you can't be so positive about him being
a young guy but he but there's something
about him like when you talk because
that implies that being a woman is not
i'm strong i'm not implying that
um but like when you talked about sports
at the end with him i
i didn't know that he was into sports as
a person
but
of course
i would have guessed he is and sure
enough he is and he knows a lot about it
wouldn't she have guessed those teams
the jets it makes me like the islanders
yes kind of like he's the mets fan like
that is yes yes for anyone listening who
is in this lives in this area the
tri-state area
there's a pretty clear difference i
would say between mets and yankees fans
and
jets and giants fans it's a different
type of person how would you articulate
that why does he embody a mets fan
versus a yankees fan i don't want to get
in trouble with yankee fans but there's
something more working-class about for
sure and
and all part of it is
also real new yorkers i mean real new
yorkers tend to be
not that we're real new yorkers we're
we're like tri-state yeah we're
connecticut yeah uh connecticutians
kinetic kitties but but to your point a
lot of fellow fairfielders that we grew
up with most of them were yankees fans
yeah their parents were wealthier the
tickets were more expensive and it comes
down to that just like the economics of
it like we were jets fans because giants
tickets were much more expensive growing
up also those teams are
historically worse
the teams that we root for are
historically worse yeah and so there's
something about
the pain that comes with rooting for
that yeah
it uh it strengthens you yes you know
it's true it's
your fandom yeah it galvanizes your
communal bond it's easy to be a yankees
fan i know they always spend the most
money and they've won 27 championships
yeah yeah these fans are always so like
disappointed when they don't when they
only make the championships you know or
they like don't make the world series
but they always get so far i mean they
always like they almost always win their
division
and you know maybe not lately
anyway ralph macchio i know hell of a
guy ah what a guy and so fun listening
to his voice also his voice surreal i
know he's like uh famously youthful you
know he's been
he referenced it a couple times how
youthful he is and how he's always been
youthful he's always looked younger than
his age he still does but his voice
still has that full energy i know to the
point where i didn't know that i hadn't
i didn't know how old he was before we
did the show and when he um
when he talked about his daughter having
a 27 year old daughter who listens
she's a shortie she's sure hopefully
she's listening now um your dad's great
by the way you know that why am i
telling you that i should tell you
something you don't know um yeah she 27
i thought god he must have had kids
really young but then i looked him up
he's
i should have looked him up before i
talked to him 59 59. he's looks and
sounds you're right so it's more more
than looking a certain way because you
know
i don't think he gets this stuff done
but like people have a way of preserving
their looks now that they didn't back
then but um yeah his voice he has this
youthful quality this kind of like and
the way he talked about
everything the way he talked was there
was this
youthful exuberance this excitement that
he had um i i just i loved the idea that
he
i don't i kept i didn't know i kept
harping on that that he his kids are
able to see
him at this
as as a well-known person because like
he said those were the lean years when
he was growing up
yeah i mean what a what a fascinating
trajectory he's had yeah in his career
going from this um
this teen idol this huge success huge
huge success everyone knows him he's in
this iconic movie that people still talk
about constantly to almost becoming of
not almost becoming a victim of his own
success yeah he talked about having a
hard time
getting in the room for my cousin vinnie
because he was the karate kid and he was
too known for that one thing i believe
that um and that led to
the lean years which i mean by my
calculations is like
20 years or something that's a long time
and now he's like back with such a
vengeance
and is so
hyper relevant again it's such a great
story it is it's similar i guess uh
to mark hamill's trajectory you know how
mark campbell just for he never heard he
didn't really too much i did a lot of
voice over stuff but he didn't do a lot
of uh
things that were
you know people were aware of like the
uh here's why it's different though
here's why it's even a better story with
ralph macho because mark hamill yeah he
came back to play star wars or luke
skywalker but those movies are yeah
they're such ensemble movies and it's
it's so much more about the movie itself
that it is about the particular actors
in them it's true that i feel like ralph
macchio in the karate kid playing that
part
is is such a um
it's such a it's so much more important
than mark hamill's role
coming back star wars you know that's
true that's true i i just i guess i just
mean psychologically for those guys for
those actors as actors you know people
who know the ups and downs and to go
from
god i mean what did i don't remember
what ralph i felt bad that i
i wasn't we weren't referencing things
he did in the 90s or the 2000s or the
two i mean it's been
quite a long time since my cousin vinnie
but they're not things that i i he
worked but they're not things that
people are particularly interested in
and he knows that he knows that he was
very comfortable talking about he was
his how he started out and the auditions
he was that's why i think you'd have to
be so it doesn't either drive you nuts
or make you um
corrupt you in any way and and i i don't
know if i said this to him but i
certainly tried i think it it was such a
good time in the bigger picture now
looking back at it it must i wonder if
it strikes him as being good timing to
have those lean years because he
probably was a much more present father
sure he said he doesn't have tattoos
he's not a tattoo guy but if he had to
get one he would get stay gold ponyboy
and he was speculating where on his body
he might get it and you suggested his
taint
um
i'm so glad
and i thought that was an interesting
thing to suggest to your boyhood idol
i was trying to make him laugh
i thought it'd be like a i thought i was
trying to well it made me laugh yeah
okay
okay let's read a letter okay
uh this is a letter from nikki cornelius
cool name yeah i was just about to say
you know both everything nicky cornelius
is a cool name i was just about to say
that
yeah what does cornelius remind you of
go
cornelius uh
yukon cornelius yes me too from rudolph
the red nose yeah reindeer cornelius and
a little like i think like cornelius
west but i know that's not his name
cornell i know
but isn't cornell short for cornelius i
don't know hopefully future guests of
the show though that would be great
um subject would you rather 2020 edition
hey guys we did it we made it through
2020 and while i know nothing is really
going to change on january 1st the idea
of a new year with a fresh start brings
a lot of hope
well i'm not one for new year's
resolutions i have decided to start a
gratitude journal so i find something
good in every day to be grateful for
even if it is just a hummus rap i like
that i graduated i thought you meant i
like a hummus wrap i do i do too but you
know what i'd be too lazy to write down
those things
and there's so many things you
definitely would be i shouldn't that's a
good idea though it is
if i had been keeping this journal
throughout 2020 discovering your podcast
would have been a big topic ah
thanks nikki as the first and basically
only podcast i've ever listened to okay
so you don't have much to compare it to
back to her i just listened to you on
armchair expert after getting caught up
on life for short it was just what i
needed to get me through the second half
of this crazy year
which is the perfect segue into my first
would you rather 2020 edition okay here
we go would you rather be stuck in an
infinite time loop for the first six
months of 2020
or the last six months of 2020.
everything that really happened during
those six months happens and you do
everything exactly as you did during
that time that's a good question oh
yeah that's it that's a good question a
good question and a really horrifying
thought thought either one yeah first or
second month
i i would say what would you say what
would you pick well here's why i would
pick the first month
first half first half i'm sorry first
six months i would pick that only
because um for part of it we were doing
we were filming the movie that we also
talk about as much as we talk about how
grateful we are to dak shepard lady the
manor we were filming that and it was
it was mostly fun i mean there were a
lot i know there were like tremendously
stressful elements of it that i wouldn't
want to relive but it was still exciting
even the stressful elements were like so
that's why you'd pick the first half and
we got a little bit of the quarantine
which i
you know i
i was doing finding good things in in in
the quarantine trying to trying to it
was scary of course and
but we like as we've said we were lucky
during the quarantine um
so i would pick the first half the
second half
became a little bit more um
well that's what i was going to say i i
think
great there are great elements of each
half and things that i would want to
hold on to
and bad elements like
like
having covet in the first half but i
would still pick the first half because
were you at a minor version still but
but i'm saying highs and lows for both
abs but i would pick the first half
because
it just got tedious the second it became
a little bored in the house in the house
board yes so the second half and i
started to get a little uh
my my nerves started to fray yeah in the
second half i think a lot of people yeah
relate to that um but really good would
you rather interesting and there's
another one yes
would you rather be stuck in quarantine
with your ex and their new significant
other
we had a similar one to this or be with
your new significant other and your ex
hmm would you rather be stuck in
quarantine with your ex and their new i
see
or be with your new significant other
and your ex um
see there's too many variables
it depends on who
which ex and also
who knows the what the person they're
with now is like yeah because most of my
exes i'm really honest with i would yeah
i don't really mind being and i like
their significant others if if i'm
imagining nx and i'm imagining a person
that you pick the x
i'm imagining a specific axe and
imagining the pers a person that they
might be dating now yeah if i had to if
i had to guess the type of person they'd
be dating now i have an image of that in
my head
so i that's one example that's one side
of it and the other side is
i'm imagining maggie with
that same x and in that scenario
i i would i would pick the latter
because
it's at least i have her yeah of course
it's different for you and i at least
have her and then i could deal with but
but that other scenario i'm sure maggie
would get along with these yeah
eventually yeah and and but the other
scenario is i'm with
just me and these two people
who i don't really want to spend a lot
of time with necessarily right so you
got to pick debbie and it would also be
tough i'm thinking of an ex that i
really
love very much and
and i and i
and i totally get along with her um
but it might be a little difficult
you know it might be a little hard we're
in very different positions we are
uh okay so thank you back to the letter
nikki thanks for all the laughs this
past year i look forward to you making
me smile and laughs more in 2021 no
pressure
oh uh and also thanks to allison brief
for ending the year off talking about
how amazing cats are yeah allison loves
cats
they aren't [ __ ] and justin it's not
their fault you're allergic to them
that's true
that is very true i don't think their
ass did i say they were [ __ ] some
cats could be [ __ ] some dogs can be
[ __ ] a lot of people can be [ __ ]
yeah uh they just want to love you and
be loved by you smiley face a nice smile
i like that smiley face that's like you
know it's the first of the non first up
from neutral smiley face it's just like
a little raised like this
yeah yes why are you laughing the way
you did it you look like a
little uh there's like faces not like
behind the eyes you glazed over your
eyes that's scary actually
okay back to nikki sorry i love you guys
nikki c
granville
massachusetts where's that granville i
think it's in the berkshires isn't it or
near there it is right up uh yeah past
uh right over the border
wow right in the heart of the berkshires
that's cool
that's really cool well thank you nikki
yes and congratulations for living in
the berkshires
and uh thanks for writing in those are
those are good it's not far from
springfield those are good would you
rathers and uh springfield massachusetts
and i'm really glad you're listening
yeah me too so let's get off granville
oh yeah but what do you think of when
you think of springfield basketball hall
of fame okay yeah me too okay who cares
um you don't bother to think about
school hall of fame we think of
springfield massachusetts um
okay well yes thanks to everyone who
heard that
if you guys want to write in our email
address i hope ralph isn't still
listening i do
yeah our email address is life is short
at wondery.com we really like getting
your letters even though we only read
one of them
uh every episode we read them all yes
and we enjoy them all almost all of them
yeah and we don't only read letters
written by people named nikki that's
true clarified that that's true you
don't have to be nicki or you don't have
to be from the berkshires that is true i
should have made that clear um so thank
you to everyone writing in and listening
and uh thank you so much uh to our
esteemed guest uh our
our childhood
idol maybe future pal maybe ralph
macchio genuine and positive yeah he
really does seem genuine and positive
doesn't he he does and i know a lot of
people can fake that a lot of people in
our profession uh fake that but you know
it seems really authentic and um i also
want to thank his his daughter i think
julie julia yeah
julia uh julia macchio
machio i don't know why i said machia i
don't either oh boy julia that's so nice
because i think i feel like you had a
lot to do with your dad doing the show
and um and you had a lot to do as it
turns out with us maybe eventually
becoming friends and i'll go into a mets
game together and everyone should go out
and watch cobra kai it's a fantastic
show
we'll talk to you next week yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me
justin long the podcast kid it's
co-hosted
by you christian long and it's also
produced by megan monaco senior producer
is michelle mish land audio engineer is
sergio enriquez on this particular
podcast there are two executive
producers one of whom is marshall louis
the second one but not lesser ernon
lopez for a company that remains
[Music]
wandery margaret do you see this
this is crazy this claire's about to
tell
dale that uh she loves him
she's in love with him and and dale
asked for the first time about her
parents the first time yeah if they
haven't had any time they've had time
together
and she they've just been like making
out and she goes out my dad's name is
this my mom's this and he's like and she
goes and
you know they met one time they only met
once and hung out once and my father she
said like this is romantic thing my
father drove across the country to be
with her to propose and
this his reaction is
what that's crazy
and
he's about to have to do that
wait
what
listen what happens
this is great wow
you think they met once
she makes terrible decisions and
three weeks later my dad showed up
at
her house
in california they met one time
[Music]
after one time she's like she thinks
it's amazing
you